we spotted  right now  they fly now confronting fear it's the  destiny of a Jedi your destiny if this  mission fails it was all for nothing  [Music]  we're not alone good people will fight  if we leave them  [Music]  not you yes it's it  our Wars the rise of Skywalker tickets  available now oh we've done all this  time we're doing there's repeal taking  one last look sir my friend  [Music]  confronting fear  [Music]  the destiny of a Jedi  your destiny  we're all in this  gland and Star Wars the rise of  Skywalker tickets available now  [Music]  confronting fear  is the destiny of a Jedi  your destiny  [Music]  the force will be with you always  [Applause]  tickets available now  you